hey youtubers is Charlie so this is
gonna be a video all about Marvel phase
four who the Avengers gonna be facing
and what's gonna be happening after
Thanos and the Infinity Gauntlet
storyline mostly Dormammu
Mephisto stuff if you haven't watched it
yet agents of shield just debuted the
Robbie ray is Ghost Rider character when
the actor was hyping up his appearance
on the series he started mentioning
things like Mephisto in the Marvel
Universe so all of a sudden you're like
hey wait a minute does that mean that
Mephisto is gonna be related to the
Avengers he's a pretty big cosmic
villain but a lot of you are probably
aware of some of the problems that
Marvel runs into with its movies and
that its IP belongs to different studios
so everything x-men and Fantastic Four
is at Fox
the problem with Mephisto is is that he
debuted in the silver surfers comic book
and usually the rule of thumb when you
want to know which characters belong to
which studio is is where did the
character debut like which title did he
debut in was it in an x-men comic well
then it probably belongs to Fox Dee Dee
debut in a Thor Akama or an Avengers
comic then it belongs to Marvel Studios
and we're just talking about movie
rights here so on the other side of the
coin you have Dormammu which is another
big Doctor Strange demonic figure from
another dimension so a lot of the Marvel
rumor mill is saying that once Thanos
leaves the Marvel Universe like once
they deal with him the big bads will be
the demonic super figures of the Marvel
Universe so you're talking about
Mephisto you're talking about Dormammu
so it makes sense that they would slowly
push into magic and that would be a
bigger thing in phase four because we
are just getting to Doctor Strange so
you can't go from like zero to Dormammu
overnight so I have a feeling we'll only
get shades of Dormammu in the Doctor
Strange movie but between Mephisto and
Dormammu
we know that Dormammu belongs to Marvel
Studios so they can do him easy slam
dunk so Mephisto is the problem the
question is is like does Marvel Studios
have rights to do him because there's a
lot of crossover with Doctor Doom Doctor
Strange Silver Surfer Fantastic Four
stuff so you think that Fox would
actually have rights to the character
and Marvel would have to bargain if
they're going to use it but like I said
we're doing Ghost Rider on agents of
shield so the big thing with Mephisto's
character is
he created the Johnny Blaze ghostwriter
so he's really important for Ghost
Rider's backstory just in general now
the one they're doing on the TV show is
a different version of the character but
Mephisto just appears in some of the
biggest Avengers related titles he was a
Thor villain during the 70s he was the
mastermind of the big twist during
Avengers disassembled when Scarlet Witch
lost her mind after she found out that
her babies weren't real
like her babies were really soul shards
of Mephisto so they just vaporized in
nothingness and she just went nuts and
no more mutants boom sets off this giant
comic book arc so Mephisto is
ever-present he is like the trickster
God that Loki wishes he could be like
people called Loki the trickster god but
technically he's not a god he's only a
God compared to normal people
Mephisto is way more powerful this is
how powerful he is he was responsible
for one more day that Spiderman art like
he basically erases a bunch of
spider-man's backstory and reboots his
life in this alternate continuity so
it's kind of up in the air but just
erring on the side of caution we'll say
Mephisto technically still belongs with
Fox meaning that his arc during the big
Infinity Gauntlet storyline will have to
go to someone else so you know some
supernatural figure in the Marvel
Universe that is a servant of fan OHS
that helps him acquire the gems but
secretly covets them for himself
what other trickster gods do we have in
the Marvel Universe that try to backstab
and double deal with everybody they
enter into contracts with oh okay we've
already got one
so Loki probably gonna take Mephisto
place in Avengers infinity war I'll make
a deal with you you won't kill me I'll
help you get the gems and then I'll
secretly try to steal the gauntlet from
you so we still need our big bad to
replace Thanos after infinity war so
that means the Dormammu moves up the
bench
big dr. strange villain becomes the next
ultimate villain to try and take over
the Marvel Universe so that's like you
know way way out there but Dormammu just
fits in nicely with the thematic things
that they're gonna be doing later in
phase four like you have Baron Mordo who
ends up becoming a servant of Dormammu
to try and backstab
ancient one and dr. strange but in the
movies right now Baron Mordo is not dr.
Strange's enemy so that's like wave
further off so we're talking beyond 2020
but let me know in the comments how much
of Dormammu do you think that we're
gonna get a peek at during Doctor
Strange just a little bit because Mads
Mikkelsen is the main villain of that
movie cuz Silius he wants to collapse
all the dimensions into one so it's a
pretty big plan but you know maybe there
is a villain behind the villain so we'll
get a tease for that in the way we got
teased with Thanos at the end of the
first Avengers film so just like when we
saw that first Avengers film like you
seethe anos and you're like oh I see
exactly where they're going they're
gonna do Infinity Gauntlet cut to six
years later and boom we have our
Gauntlet storyline I think the real
question now is it like if they make
Dormammu like the new Big Bad at the
Marvel Universe and phase four what is
going to be the timeline for his grand
plan to play out will it be another
three phase cycles so you have phase
four is kind of like teeing up all these
new characters phase five phase six is
the one that closes it down with like
their version of what Avengers infinity
war is going to mean for Phase three
the Infinity Gauntlet storyline is
really meant to bookend all the stuff
that they've been dealing with these
first three phases and kind of tee up
where the characters are going next so
when we get to that next Avengers film
that's currently untitled it was
originally titled infinity War part 2
but they've already changed that they're
like we're gonna call it something else
but they haven't said what it is in
they're writing the script for that
while they're writing the script for
infinity War part 1 so like they already
know what the story is they just they
don't want to reveal what the title is
because I feel like it's gonna be New
Avengers or all-new all-different
Avengers
it'll just spoil a lot of what's going
to be happening during the first
infinity war movie so they're just
holding off on revealing what that's
going to be but just to be clear just to
give you an idea of like the grand scope
of dormammu's character he's presented
as kind of like this multi-dimensional
energy source that predates the universe
and was banished by his contemporaries
it's kind of like a lucifer type story
only amongst cosmic beings like grand
cosmic beings something way worse than
demons so at various points in the
comics he's tried to increase his powers
by merging with other energies
like merging his being with other energy
sources merging mystical dimensions so
you can see how the Doctor Strange movie
might invoke that because kuselias is
supposedly trying to collapse all
dimensions into one so I feel like
Dormammu has to be in there somewhere
but he's in a mortal being as you would
expect it has absolutely no problem
waiting billions of years for plans to
bear fruit so one of the challenges I
think that Marvel is gonna have with a
character like that is making him feel
grounded for people that just don't
really go down for magical stories like
that like Doctor Strange is kind of a
hard character to sell anyway so I feel
like if they can do that then they can
totally do Dormammu but like you have
characters like The Living Tribunal like
the living essence of the multiverse
probably not gonna see that in the
movies so we know whatever form Dormammu
takes in the Marvel Cinematic Universe
it'll probably be really easy for you to
take your friend or like your little
brother and for him to understand that
but when you go see Doctor Strange in
November just be sure to keep your eyes
peeled for references to the Dark
Dimension or otherworldly magical
dimensions because those are the dark
corners where Dormammu sits waiting so
that's all before infinity war so that's
kind of like putting the cart in front
of the horse so we're way off don't need
to worry about it now it's just that
Marvel is really good at laying seeds
that they pay off years later so just
like we saw a nose at the end of the
first Avengers film we will see teases
for phase four stuff in the Doctor
Strange movie but if you guys didn't
know there is a new round of the Captain
America giveaway that's going on now I
started my agents of shield video all
you have to do to enter is be a
subscriber and leave a comment on this
video and some of you guys have said
that you've had problems clicking on the
links at the end of my videos like the
videos get cut off or something like
that there's a new feature that YouTube
rolled out but it's not on like every
single browser so if the videos get cut
off I always add the links that I point
to in the description below so you can
always find that stuff down below but
get hype because the Luke Cage is
dropping next week and agents of shield
is actually pretty good I'm really
surprised with how good it was this week
so agents of shield episode 2 and Luke
Cage episode 1 all dropping next week
while you guys wait for that to post you
can click here for my Ghost Rider
episode 1 video and you can click here
for my
infinity war Thanos teaser thank you so
much watching everybody let's high five
I'll see you guys tonight